قصتنا بالشارع اليوم مع العم ابو احمد رجل
80 الذي يزال يعمل في مهنه صناعه كراسي
القش فوق سطح منزله كان المكان البديل عن
محله الذي خسره ليكمل مسيرته في صناعه
كراسي القش المهنه التي اتقنها منذ الصغر
يعمل ابو احمد في هذه المهنه منذ 57 عاما
حيث تعلمها على يد والدته ويعلمها لاولاده
من من هم عاطلون عن العمل اليوم نتعرف
اكثر على ابو احمد شيخ مهنه صناعه كراسي
القشر الذي سيكون ضيفنا في فقره قصهنا
الشارع ما علينا
ونرحب مع نرحب ارينا ادويه مراتبه صباح
العربيه تعرفنا على العم احمد تفضل يا ريت
صباح الخير
بفضل الحرفيين وقد يكون الحاج خضر سكاف
اخيرهم في طرابلس هو الذي يحاول الحفاظ
على المهنه وقد حاول ايضا تمريرها الى
اولاده ولكن هذا الجيل الجديد يعني يرغب
بالمهن الحره والاسرع كون هذه المهنه
تحتاج الى كثير من الصبر صباح الخير حاج
هدر
يمكن حضرتك يعني اخر الحرفيين اللي بعدهم
بيعملوا هالكراسي القش بطرابلس خبرني عنه
هذا الكرسي يعني انت اليوم تعمل من الالف
للياء
خبرني المراحل اللي بتمر فيها
ولا اكثر من هيك
كبيره صغيره
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
اليوم هذا الكرسي حياتها بتبلش بيسهل عكار
خبرني يعني بتستمده من عكار
[موسيقى]
بص شايف باب غزه
ولد واحد يعني
بيروح معي على الاكل
سبع سنين ما شاء الله يمكن لك اكثر من 70
سنه
الكبير قبل محمد بيشتغل في هلا
طبعا يعني الحج هنا
يشكو اهمال الدوله وتقصيره بحق الحرفيين
ولكنه يسعى قدر الامكان الى الاستمرار
بهذه الحرفه كما يسميها ونقلها الى اولاده
رغم انهم يفضلون المهن الحره
انا عم بتابع قابلتك مع حج احمد وانا يعني
لعيون الحج احمد راح اشترك كراسي بس انا
حابه هيك ارجع اقول له يعني كيف بدك
تقنعني اشتري الاشعه على حساب الكرسي
الكلاسيك
سؤالي كيف بده ينافس كراسي البلاستيك
على لبنان وبدي اشتري بين كرسي اشرب
بلاستيك كيف بده يقنعني اشتري القش بدل
البلاستيك
عم تسالي اذا هي اجت على لبنان وبدها
تشتري كرسي من عندك كيف بدك تقنعه احسن من
البلاستيك
تحمل اكثر
[موسيقى]
اه عنا ابيض يعني ولد يا عم معاكسلين
عبيطه ههه
متينه الكرسي نظرا للقاعده الخشبيه
هنستعمله انواع خشبيه اخشاب متينه لان
ايضا مصنوعه بحب يعني هاي كرسي مصنوعه لك
خصيصا بتكون تخيل يعني مش بس القصه
بالمثانه القصه يعني
بالخصوصيه اللي بتاخذيها كمان من هون
بدي اقصد على سهام انت ما شفتي النظرات
اللي اعطتني اياهم كثير احنا نقول خلي
البئر شكرا